the 3ds had a significant hardware
upgrade this year but the best games for
Nintendo's enduring handheld play great
whether you're on a launch system or a
brand-new machine it's a testament to
the lasting appeal and versatility of
the handheld that you always have a
choice of both short and simple mobile
like fair and deep triple-a experiences
and that versatility is reflected in the
best 3ds games of 2015 despite monster
hunter's dominance in japan the series
has struggled to find similar success in
the West but this year's entry Monster
Hunter 4 ultimate goes a long way toward
rectifying what made earlier games in
the franchise so obtuse and
unapproachable it doesn't dump down the
combat but the main story progression
makes learning the game's robust battle
systems more accessible and even when
you're without a local or online partner
you're given some hearty feline
companions that make tackling even the
toughest beasts possible on your own
youkai watch fills the void left by a
year without a traditional Pokemon game
on its surface it may sound like just
another imitation of game freak's hit
series but the battle system sets yokai
watch a partner the active RPG combat
requires quick reflexes and active
monitoring of your party but you'll also
have to think about team layout and
balancing the abilities of your fighters
it might not replace Pokemon entirely
but it's a worthy alternative with a lot
of promise for future installments and
spin-offs
at first glance you might not guess that
the minimalistic box boy was created by
the same development studio behind the
colorful and majid ative kirby series
but box boys simple graphics balaiah
deep satisfying puzzle platformer your
abilities slowly expand but the gameplay
never becomes unnecessarily complicated
the puzzles require careful
consideration not split-second
button-pressing like any great puzzle
game it's true strength lies in giving
you seemingly insurmountable puzzles of
devilish complexity but also laying out
all the skills you need to solve them at
your fingertips
Triforce Heroes might seem like an odd
addition to our best 3 vs games list and
received an average score but it still
has moments of extreme excellence the
soundtrack is both original and totally
rich and the little graphical flourishes
in the game's backgrounds make you feel
like you're exploring a living
environment when you're playing with
friends Triforce Heroes captures the
adventure and puzzle solving elements
intrinsic to any great Zelda game it
isn't as much fun when playing solo and
the main adventure ends too quickly but
if you can find a party of dedicated
adventurers to brave the games dungeons
with this is still an epic quest
stretchmo reflects a very different
Nintendo from years past the fun solid
puzzle-solving builds off of earlier
games in the franchise but what sets
stretchmo apart is it's free to start
model stretchmo borrows the mobile like
business model that nintendo has
recently started implementing in more
games start for free pay to unlock more
content if you like it
games like stretch mode show how
Nintendo is bridging the gap between the
mobile and console worlds so that no
matter what gamers come out on top
it's been a great year for 3ds 2015 is
any indication we expect to see more of
the same mix of appealing games in
genres on 3ds going into the new year
and with the NX on the horizon might
even see Nintendo experimenting with
entirely new ways to play and enjoy
games on its popular handheld gaming
system
you